[Music]
welcome back to Harbor onbox today we're
taking a look at another product that I
don't know why are we even doing this I
can't take it anymore guys I am starting
to lose it I can't reveiew another
product that doesn't make sense or
doesn't offer anything new it's been
like 2 years now make it stop but before
you do today's sponsor spot is brought
to you by Asus and their latest range
z790 motherboards supporting 12th 13th
and 14th generation Intel core
processors for those of you seeking a
budget friendly option one of our
favorite z790 motherboards is the tough
gaming z790 Plus available in either
ddr4 or ddr5 variants with and without
Wi-Fi there's also the recently updated
version called the tough gaming z790 Pro
featuring ddr5 exclusively but for those
of you seeking something a bit more
high-end we've tested a number of
excellent z790 stricks Sports and for my
personal gaming system I'm using the Rog
STX z790 F gaming Wi-Fi Which packs
loads of usb3 ports PD 3.13 W charging
and a powerful vcor vrm using 16 90 AMP
power stages and right now for
Australian viewers you'll receive a free
Corsair Vengeance RGB 32 GB ddr5 6000 C
36 memory kit when you purchase select
Asus z790 motherboards with an Asus
all-in-one liquid cooler so for more
information please check the link in the
video description okay so in all
seriousness the last year or so of PC
Harbor releases have been they've been
pretty damn boring sure there has been
the odd exciting or interesting product
release but overall the bulk of the
releases have been pretty much like what
we have here for you today and that is
to say they've been a bit underwhelming
but don't get me wrong I am a big fan of
price Cuts so that aspect of today's
release I am totally on board for but
really that's all we have for you today
a price cut and I fear it may even be
too little too late that being the case
I'm actually not quite sure what we're
doing here and that's awkward because
it's kind of my job and has been for
over 20 years now I mean we are here to
review nvidia's new GeForce RTX 480
super which you'd assume is a special
version of the original RTX 480 but
really it's basically just the original
RTX 480 with a much needed price cut so
why call it the RTX 480 Super Why Not
Just announce an official price cut for
the RTX 480 and call it a day well you
might think that's because Nvidia
doesn't officially discount their
products but that's not the case at all
the RTX 470 for example just received an
official price cut from $600 to $550 to
make way for the 470 super so they were
willing to do it for the RTX 470 but for
some reason not the
4080 instead they've reworked the RTX
480 to create the 480 super using the
full a103 silicon which means you get a
slight increase in corat with faster
memory so then the 40 super is a new
product well technically yeah it is but
in reality also not really and last week
we saw just how underwhelming the RTX
4072 super performance uplift was but
compared to what we're getting here the
ti super was kind of a big deal
that's because the RTX 480 super
delivers a 5% increase in cause a 2%
frequency boost and memory that is
clocked 3% higher all said and done you
can expect up to a 5% performance
increase in video's told us to expect
around 3% and everything else remains
pretty well the same so that means
you're getting the same vram capacity
and all that other good stuff of course
the big change here is the price Nvidia
has reduced the MSRP from $1,200 us with
the original 480 to $1,000 us for this
new super version so that's good but
realistically Nvidia were forced to do
this anyway the RTX 480 wasn't that
popular at $1,200 us and Midway through
the product cycle sales were pretty
dead so then I guess the question is is
a 177% price cut and a very minor bump
in performance enough to revive the RTX
480 well to find out we're skipping all
of the individual game benchmarks as the
data is super boring pun intended there
and instead we're going to dive into the
12 game average data and then look at
cost per frame rate tracing all that
sort of stuff as a as an average so
let's go do
that we'll start with the 1080p data
because why not we have it though of
course a lot of the games here were CPU
Limited in any case we see that on
average the 4080 super is 2% faster than
the original original 480 making it just
2% slower than the 7900 XTX but let's
move on to the 1440p
results at 40 and 40p the 480 super is
just 3% faster than the original 480 and
nid told is well ahead of time to expect
around a 3% uplift so they we're right
on the money there they also stress that
this release is really all about that
new $11,000 us
MSRP finally at the 4K resolution the
4080 super is 4% faster than the
original 480
though this did mean it was 9% slower
than the 7900 XTX and 24% slower than
the RTX 490 so for strictly
rasterization performance AMD still has
a slight performance lead with the 7900
XTX so let's take a look at rate tracing
as you can see ra tracing performance
does remain an issue for AMD and with a
mixture of titles the 7900 XTX averaged
77 FPS at 1440p making the 480 super 31%
faster that's a massive performance
difference now here's a look at the MSRP
cost per Frame data based on the
rasterization numbers when compared to
the original 480 this new super version
is 19% better value thanks to slightly
better performance and of course a $200
discount but as we found with the other
super refresh models the 4080 super is
really what the 480 should have been
when it was first released back in late
2022 and highlighting just how poor Val
the original 480 was and still is is the
retail pricing data the 19% Improvement
in value for the 480 super still sees it
situated towards the bottom of our graph
but at least it's matching what the 4070
TI delivers which I suppose isn't great
but for a high in GeForce 40 series GPU
it's also about as good as it gets and I
wasn't wrapped with the 470 TI super but
honestly having now seen what the 480
super has to offer it doesn't seem all
that that bad at least there you got the
upgrade to 16 GB of
vram for the 480 super to match the
value of the 470 TI super it would need
to cost no more than
$940 us but I guess there has to be some
kind of Premium associated with that 480
series
branding also as underwhelming as the
$1,000 480 super looks here it does
still manage to out compete the $980
7900 xdx despite costing 6% more per
frame and I say this because the
additional features of the GeForce GPU
which I will talk about a bit later on
the video make the 480 super a better
deal in our opinion stuff like rate
tracing performance and higher quality
upscaling speaking of R tracing here's a
look at the cost per frame based on our
10 game average data at 1440p of course
using Road tracing previously the 1700
XTX offered similar value to the RTX 480
despite being a little over 20% slower
on average but with the updated pricing
the 4080 super is over 20% better value
than the 7900 XTX and in fact even the
much cheaper previous generation radium
Parts can't hold a candle to the value
of the 4080 super here finally let's
take a look at the cost per Frame data
calculated using the 4K results and
again we'll start with the msrps just to
see where things should be and have
these current generation models compared
to previous
generations previously at 4 40p we found
that the 4080 super was just 3% more
costly per frame than the 7900 XTX but
now at 4K the results further favor the
Radeon GPU as it's now 9% better value
so at least relative to the 7900 XTX the
480 super does better at
1440p then if we look at the current
retail pricing we see the 480 super is
12% more costly per frame when compared
to the radon GPU so for those of you
interested purely in rasterization
performance perance this is the point
where we feel that the 7900 XTX starts
to become a viable option so that is to
say when it's offering more than a 10%
discount in terms of cost per frame so
there you have it the RTX 480 is now 3
to 4% faster and it costs $200 us less
so it's all positive in that sense but
is it enough after 14 months as I said
earlier this really is what the RTX 480
should have been from the start and and
even then it would have only been really
a very Mild improvement over the RTX 380
for it to be a true generational uplift
it would need to cost no more than $800
so that explains why the RTX 480 was so
poorly received upon launch and
ultimately didn't sell that well of
course Nvidia is none too phased given
the demand AI has generated for their
gpus they really lucked it out the
moment crypto went
bust the question Still Remains though
is a 1,000
RTX 480 an attractive option in early
2024 I asked this because I suspect most
who wanted this level of performance
already pulled the trigger on a 480 at
$1,200 us or got the 7900 XTX for
$1,000 so I'm not really sure if those
who have been holding out all this time
for something better are going to jump
on a
$1,480 but I suppose if you are in the
market for a high in GPU and your can
accommodate for an RTX 480 super or 7900
XTX you're probably asking yourself
which one should you get for me the 480
super it's a pretty easy pick here given
that they both do cost around $11,000 us
and look it's easy enough to downplay
stuff like R tracing and upscaling as
key selling points on GeForce gpus that
are priced below $500 US and I don't
mean we got of a way to do so rather
they've proven to be questionable
features when looked at in depth for
example lower and GeForce gpus such such
as those in the 4060 series offer a
heavily compromised raate tracing
experience both in terms of visual
quality and the frame rate
performance moreover upscaling doesn't
work that well at 1080p the quality is
quite poor as there simply isn't enough
pixel data to work with but for high-end
products that can provide frame rates
North of 60 FPS while making heavy use
of rate traced effects in games such as
cyber Punk it does become a key selling
point or at least it can be depending on
your preferences likewise because you're
able to game at at least 40 40p or
really you'd probably be gaming at 4K
upscaling becomes a useful tool as it
works considerably better at higher
resolutions and it really is quite
fantastic at
4K so you can lean much more heavily on
nvidia's Superior rate racing
performance and upscaling quality when
comparing the 480 super to amd's radon
RX 7900
XTX as it stands the radon GP is just
10% better value based on our 4K
rasterization data which means it really
needs to drop down to at least $900 and
even then a lot of Gamers will easily
justify the $100 premium to take
advantage of raid tracing and dlss so
it'll be very interesting to see if AMD
makes a much needed pricing correction
really to their entire radon lineup but
in this context very much need to make a
correction there to the 17900
XTX and yeah now the uh RTX
480 super officially cost $1,000 us uh
let me know what you think about this
particular produ for $1,000 us do you
think it's a good deal uh if you are
holding out has this entire student hour
going by what is essentially an RTX 480
after a 14mon wait or are you just
holding out for the next Generation in
the hope that that actually improve
stuff like cost per frame so let me know
about that in the comment section below
and I'll be sure to to read your
feedback also don't forget to like the
video subscribe for more content and if
you'd like to support us directly we
have float plan patreon signing up to
either one of those things we give you
access to our exclusive Discord server
for members only uh monthly live stream
for members only Q&A stuff behind the
scenes content a lot of cool things
there so check it out if you're
interested but if not that is perfectly
fine and I would like to thank you for
watching this video I'm your host Steve
see you again next
time
[Music]